Not long ago we had dealt with the roots we had
We only used the square root
We saw that if you typed the root code so and put it
Underneath 9, this means I want the square root of 9
It is positive 3
Or can tell the positive square root for 9
What is the implicit concept of this is that I want
Take the square root
I can write it like this
You can type the root code so and so
The 2 is here, which also means the square root
Square root of number 9
Find a number if you square it
I'll get 9
The root code does not
Apply only in the case of square root
It can change the value under the root and take
Root any number
For example, if you want to ask you, how much - you can
Imagine what is called cubism root, or can be called
The third root of 27
how much?
Well, it 's any number that raises the power to 3
I get 27
Well, the only number that if raised to force 3
I'll get 27 is 3
3 × 3 × 3 = 27
Ie 9 × 3 = 27
If anyone else asks me
If we had 16 - I would do this in a different color
If we have 16 I want to find its quadrilateral root
What is the number that if I hit it myself 4 times I will get 16?
If you do not realize this quickly, you can
To analyze 16 factors
So you find him
To see it
16 = 2 × 8
8 is 2 × 4
And 4 is 2 × 2
That is, this equals the quadratic root of 2 x 2
× 2 × 2
We have four of the number 2 here
Well, we have four of the number 2 multiplied by each other, if the quadrant root
It will be 2
This can be reviewed on it
The quadruple root because it is all-2
You will succeed as well
.
Just as you hit square roots, you should
Hit the four roots
But the root symbol means the root
Thus, we have spread
Traditional square roots
I wish now that you can simplify the roots
Carrying higher root forces
So let's try several examples
Let me say I want to simplify this phrase
Root V for 96
As I said earlier, let's analyze the value of its factors
If 96 is 2 x 48
And 48 = 2 x 24
24 is 2 × 12
And 12 = 2 x 6
And 6 are 2 × 3
If the fifth root equals 2 × 2 × 2
2 × 2 ×
2 × 2 × 2 × 2 × 2
X 3
Or in another way, can be written on a picture
Fractional forces
They can be considered as fractional powers
We have already talked about this
It is equal to 2 × 2 × 2 × 2 ×
2 x 3 ^ 1/5
Let me clarify this
If we want to extract the root n for a number, it will be equal to taking
This number is 1 / n
These words are equal
If we take this number to force 1/5, then this
Same as 2 × 2 × 2 × 2
X 2 ^ 1/5
X 3 ^ 1/5
I now have numbers multiplied by each other
I have 2 multiplied by herself 5 times
I raised it to force 1/5
Well, power 1/5 equals 2
Or that the fifth root will equal 2
If we have 2 here
This will be 3 ^ 1/5
(2 x 3) ^ 1/5
You can also simplify them
But if we want to keep it root, we can write it
So: 2 x root v for 3
Let us try another question
We will try another matter
I will use the variables now
To transfer we want to simplify the sixth root of 64
X x ^ 8
Let's begin with 64 first
64 = 2 × 32 and 32 × 2 × 16
16 is 2 × 8
And 8 are 2 × 4
And 4 = 2 x 2
If we have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
We have 2 ^ 6
Ie the value is equal to the sixth root of 2 ^ 6
This is the 64-x x ^ 8
Now, the sixth root for 2 ^ 6
direct
This part will equal 2
It will be 2 x x root
For x ^ 8
x ^ 8
How can this be simplified?
Well, x ^ 8, equals x ^ 6
X x ^ 2
We have the same foundation, so we gather the foundations
Which equals x ^ 8
This equals 2 x x root for x ^ 6
X x ^ 2
The sixth root, this part, the sixth root
For x ^ 6, is x
If this equals 2 × x ×
The sixth root of x ^ 2
Now, we can simplify these more if
I thought about it
Remember, that phrase
Equivalent (x ^ 2) ^ 1/6
And if you remember the properties of the foundations, when it is
Raises the number of a certain amount, and then raises the whole amount
For another, Vesaisoui
x ^ 2 × 1/6
Or - let me write this - 2 x 1/6,
Equally - I should not forget that I have 2x here
If I have 2x here and 2x here
It is the same as 2x
X x ^ 2/6
Or, if we want to write it simpler or less
Common, we get 2x × x ^ - what we have
Here? x ^ 1/3
If you want to type it root, you can type it
So: 2 × 2x × the third root of x
Or think of it in another way, you could say--
If we can move from this point
We can write this
We can ignore this, as we did before
Can say, that this equals 2 ×
(x ^ 8) ^ 1/6
This is equal to 2 × x ^
8 x 1/6 - x ^ 8/6
Now we can do a shortcut to break
The amount becomes 2 × x ^ 4/3
This and that are equal
Why?
Because we have 2 x x or 2 x x ^ 1
X x ^ 1/3
Add 1 to 1/3, get 4/3
I hope you found this lesson
Pleasing
I think it is useful and you will find it in the main factor
If you want to find the root of vi, it will be on
Find a basic factor that is repeated six times
And then I can find a value of 2 ^ 6
Anyway, I hope you found this explanation useful